how's it going BR my
name my name welcome back to a laughing
in the darkness isn't that fantastic I
don't always laugh with when I do it's
nothing I'm sorry I'm not going to I'm
okay I did it whatever so who holy [__]
hey he's pumped like oh yeah let's see
if I can catch that little [__] hey
hey hey hey hey hey come here what are
you doing I'm sorry I'm just really
pumped oh okay proceed
oh you stop oh he's still a little
pumped all right so I found this dagger
while I was
uh I'm
talking I don't care how pumped you are
yes that's what I thought I'd stab him
right in the chest and ke just
teleported in front of his body hey hey
hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey calm
down hey you catch me you now will win
all the gold and prostitute really no
it's a [__]
die you meanie all right I have a
girlfriend I don't want to all right
let's go in there we can't
perhaps stupid clowns everywhere no one
likes a clown does anyone actually like
like a clown anyone raise your hand if
you like clowns I think so hey put your
hands down that's better all right so
there's a door over here maybe that's
AIT don't look at me like that clowns
you little [__] hey you see that I'm
going in here and you just can stop
smiling all right it freaks me out
okay do we have spiders on the wall it's
hello boy I got a note here for you all
right pick it hide but why let's read
the notes first for the safety we need
make a key for the big door to next room
all right nobody will use this needle to
open the door only my servants and me
are allowed to enter the Next Room The
Secret of this house are in there must
be protected I swear to God if someone
tries to steal this needle demons can
get him holy [__] that's one awesome
needle all right I'm sorry needle but we
have to hide batt whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa B don't you dare [__] tell
me where I am all right I'm hiding
here oh no what the hell is
that what the hell are you wa hey ah w w
he kill the battle he should be on my
side oh no no no no no
Sorita what the hell who
that no no no don't chew don't chew I
don't like it when you
chew all right B I killed one of your he
killed one of your friends too No One Is
Safe you will all die you little [__]
stop saying that Twilight Sparkle or
whatever your name is I'm not a brony
I'm just and I read the comments so I
know their names that's why all right
everyone's coming is he Bron I don't we
don't even have my little how am I
supposed
to anyway I don't I I never been like
anything like so um yeah that's more
clowns on the wall isn't that lovely hey
how you doing he's happy sh I'm glad
you're happy most happy hey has a twin
over there hey did you know this you
have a twin over there all right he's
oblivious but it's okay people are
allowed to be I lost Jesus Christ what
was that thing I can't tell if it's with
us or without us what and made no sense
I know all right what is that what is
all this I really have to pee you know
when does Daniel ever pee all right I
picked up stupid Monsters and stuff why
is this bed glowing all right St we're
out of here so totally out of here H up
with your new attitude so
to yes yes yes this will all be over
this will all be over soon it will all
be
over BS I [__] hate you D it wasn't
me who kill your budy it wasn't me I
[__] swear back off you little
shits [__] me I hate
battles [__] hate all you what's the
point of that where's
saano where is he bring me to him saano
where are you oh there you are silly
pants all right I'm fine nothing
happened baby you can calm your pants
now they are calm no they're not look
again okay they are not calm let's go
here I can't leave without my answers I
don't really need answers I would love
to leave this place all right so we have
another another [__]
key why I do not know cuz it doesn't go
to any of the doors oh it does whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what's going on
in here it's F enough ah [__] it I'll go
without him I don't need okay I need him
but it's this one room got a man up
sometimes and say hi to the Clowny how
you doing Clowny why is these things on
the wall Clowny like your face Clowny
this sh what are you doing watching him
I don't like that oh there it is there's
the key let me just grab that [__] say
bye to the Clowny and let's proceed to
the other door more Cloud probably this
one all right whoever made this model
really loves keys and doors but it's
okay it's okay cuz we have more keys is
this really necessary huh really you're
laughing now but I will laugh now later
at
your poor poor use of
makeup that mascara will totally come
off all right uh what do we have here
more keys probably this is
stuck so oh what are you doing you will
get all what the hell all right um so oh
another note I can't live like this I
let him I kill them all oops sorry I
didn't mean to do that I kill them all
because I want to be better paid that
makes sense all right I always want
mentioned that it's just for the kids I
thought for one second and said to them
okay fine I'll bring you the money safe
I lar them into LOL small room and th
close the lol they screamed and L out
the son of a [__] I screamed started
crying while I pulled the lever for the
gas pipe and I in front of my eyes off
the kids the clowns died I killed them
all's he's a good guy I like him I would
get in prison then I saw the little
yanic and running out of the fun house
he was too far away to catch but that
was it a few ago I drank my toxic post
and now I'm lying in my bed until tell
my death all right Funky
Music funky clown killing music isn't
that fantastic is there something hiding
here there always something hiding are
you hiding something from me
of course you aren't you're a [__] I'll
make you my [__] there's always some
[__] key hiding is it hey I have a
lantern I didn't even know all right oh
what the [__] was that oh [__]
my that little clown
[__] I hate clown
[__] why would they [__] clowns it
make no sense they're not sexy I guess
some of I Spit on my screen
sorry
screen what was that good for that was
totally Su hello spy Jesus Christ I
heard you from there are you all
right did you pee your pants it's okay
you can tell me all right finally it's
over [__] over music by me pretty
cool music that they made themselves at
least if they did I don't know thanks
for playing thanks for making it I
suppose you little [__] I'm just
King all right that was kind of short
how long did I
record I love as soon as I like record
an 8 minute video I mean the mod is
[__] over and every I was like the
video is so short it's like what do you
want me to do it's
over you bros you bros just don't know
it sometimes I guess we can look at can
there if that wouldn't help making a
short video should longer look look at
that canina he's like just as big as
that girl what does it say
can it's for sale are you kidding me I
could buy this hey hi my name is Marin I
have a bunny holy [__] it's huge they
sell this I love him and I'm interested
in buying him no wait selling
him I don't want to use him to food for
food what yeah I don't want that you use
him to eat food what wait is he saying
that I'm not allowed to eat him well
[__] that [__] it's going to eat that
[__] ah [__] Swedish ads man you
never know look at the they are so cute
look at that one he's like oh I'm going
to sneak up on these oh wait those are
sleeping he's like I'm going to bur them
when they're finally asleep then got rap
their bodies hey this one is
like I
snorted I'm actually all black but I
snorted some fine ass cocaine all right
uh this one did that too oh look look at
that look at it how cute that looks like
a penis holy [__] that
definitely looks
like I'm sorry I don't know what's wrong
with me um so yeah right oh 10 minutes
you happy now hey you got your can like
you enjoy subscribe to come bro today
and I'll see you in whatever video I try
to make next um I'm kind of looking for
customs more custom storage to play like
something longer and unique
uh if you have one I always listen to
suggestions so leave me a suggestion
I'll do that and that's pretty much
[Music]
it don't look don't
look who that
is I don't remember
actually no no no something it's
obviously not right it's obvious